You know his name.
Fifth Doctor:
"I'm the Doctor..."
You know his face...es
And you know his mission.
First Doctor:
"Always search for truth."
"My truth is in the stars."
Unless you're not from the United Kingdom.
Then you probably don't know any of those things.
Now, relive over 30 years of classic sci-fi television
that will determine once and for all if you're a fan of Doctor Who
or a Doctor Who fan.
[MANIACAL CLOWN LAUGHTER]
Classic Doctor Who
Meet the Doctor.
A Time Lord from the planet Gallifrey who travels through space-time in a machine called the TARDIS.
And if that's already too weird for you, tap out now.
Because it's about to get a whole lot weirder.
Seventh Doctor:
"We're on the planet of the cheetah people, intelligent carnivores."
Journey through three decades of adventure
as the show
-er, I mean, the Doctor-
keeps things fresh by regenerating into new bodies every few years.
Like...
The crabby old man Doctor.
First Doctor:
Hold that and shut up, will you?
The Beatle-haircut childlike Doctor.
General:
"You've caused me a great deal of trouble!"
Second Doctor:
"Good! I'm very glad to hear it!"
The snake-tatted, kung-fu, Austin Powers Doctor.
The "this is what most people think all of classic Doctor Who is" Doctor.
Fourth Doctor:
"Have a jelly baby, and don't forget to brush your teeth."
The "he seems nice" Doctor.
Fifth Doctor:
"It's absolutely splendid!"
The "kind of arrogant even for the Doctor" Doctor.
SIxth Doctor:
"Ah..."
Sixth Doctor:
"A noble brow."
The "almost-out-of-gas-coasting-on goodwill" Doctor.
Seventh Doctor:
"Yeti, Autons, Daleks."
"Cybermen and Silurians!"
And the TV movie one-off George Lazenby Doctor.
Eighth Doctor:
WHO
AM
Eighth Doctor:
I?!
But no matter which Doctor is operating the TARDIS,
one thing remains constant:
He is either the most overrated or underrated Doctor of all time
in either the most overrated or underrated era of the show.
Okay, look.
Getting Doctor Who fans to agree on who's the best Doctor
is like trying to watch every episode of Doctor Who.
It's pretty much impossible.
So why even try?
Watch as the Doctor and his companions take on some of the most iconic villains of all time.
Like the Daleks.
Black Dalek:
Exterminate him! Exterminate him! Exterminate him!
The Cybermen.
Cyberleader:
"We meet again...
"Doctor."
And the evil Time Lord, the Master.
[INSANE LAUGHTER]
Then spend the other 90% of the show watching whatever villains the crew could throw together on a low budget.
Like...
Killer mannequins!
Third Doctor:
"Look out! Auton!"
The bubble wrap monster!
Rubber spiders!
The Great One:
"I shall be the ruler of the entire universe!"
The Gimp from Pulp Fiction!
Sharaz Jek:
"I will pay 8 kilos for the next shipment!"
A series of dudes with buckets on their heads!
Knight:
"'Tis a devil from Hell!"
Sontaran:
"Hmph!"
The Inflatable Plastic Chair of Doom!
And some villains that it sounds like they're just making up on the spot.
Third Doctor:
"They're Dæmons from the planet Dæmos!"
Watch them face off in stories serialized across three, four, six, or even ten episodes
jam-packed with enough plot to fill...
maybe two?
Dalek 1:
"We know the Thals are able to live on the surface."
Dalek 2:
"And that they must have got immunity."
Dalek 1:
"Perhaps it is a drug."
"Is it failing them now?"
Dalek 1:
"Why are these-"
Come on, Whovians.
Even you have to admit, this show is very
deliberate
...ly drawn out.
Witness the paradox that is classic Doctor Who.
A show that's both timeless
and completely out of date.
First Doctor:
"What you need is a jolly good smacked bottom!"
Thrill as it seems to predict future phenomena like "The Matrix".
Fourth:
"Goth must have his own link with the Matrix!"
The Borg.
Dalek:
RESISTANCE IS USELESS.
Cyberman:
This trial is futile.
Stephen King.
First Doctor:
"I shall have to go to the Dark Tower."
And
"Bee Movie"?
Third Doctor:
"According to classical aerodynamics, it is impossible for a bumblebee to fly!"
While also being completely inappropriate for modern times.
Henry Gordon Jago:
"For one thing, I could swear he was a Chinese."
Li H'sen Chang:
"I feel no pain. The opium..."
Fourth Doctor:
"Are they all Chinese?"
Jago:
"Gutter scrapings of Shanghai!"
Fourth Doctor:
"And one midget."
And that's just from the episode The Talons of Weng Chiang!
Li H'sen Chang:
"I understand we all look the same."
Wow.
So if you like TV shows that you can easily kick back and watch on Netflix,
then definitely DON'T start watching Doctor Who.
The Robot:
I am confused!
As this completionist nightmare will send you scrambling
to find episodes that the BBC erased decades ago
by hunting down dozens of DVD boxsets,
animated recreations,
and audio plays
while you secretly pray that all of it just magically turns up like those episodes from Africa.
But if you do somehow make it through all 26 series, specials, and TV movies,
then answer me this:
Why do Doctor Who fans get so angry every time people call him Doctor Who?
Fourth Doctor:
"I'm the Doctor! I keep telling you that!"
When that's what the SHOW called him for EIGHTEEN YEARS!
First Doctor:
"You don't understand."
I knew you wouldn't! Never mind."
Dalek:
UNDER ATTACK!
"You think for one moment that I forget that I bear the sacred blood of the
"They're about to transfer their crystal to the Hecate
"the more the thoughts will doubt you the more you must
Convince all flock that you are -doctor who refernece-"
and you're both nuts Ayutthaya, dr. Su turn around I'm content
No, I shan't- You shan't take him!
You found the inner conta- compartment containing three Daleks?!
"The accumulation of evidence is
overwhelming"
Sacrifice
Okay, okay, I'll do anything how this is the Big Finish audio place I watched k9 and company just make it stop
So the sonic screwdriver that's basically just a fancy door opener, right
Yep, that's what I thought
Now that you know the doctors history
You're ready to check out our trailer for modern Doctor Who covering everything since the 2005 reboot click above to check it out
Trust me. I'm the epic voice guy. I am definitely a madman in the box
Hello, I'm the doctor. Would you like a jelly, baby?